a fire at a southeast valley business
complex leaving a lot of people with a
lot of questions at least two businesses
destroyed after the roof collapsed at a
building on sunrise near eastern just
north of sunset park joe moeller is
there with a look at the damage tonight
joe
well a few business owners are now
trying to figure out what is next after
this place take a look this fence is now
up and the debris was pulled out by
investigators earlier and you can see it
is all boarded up you can still smell
that that smell of smoke outside of this
building now investigators are trying to
figure out what caused all this
it's pretty damaged in there it's a
business owner's worst nightmare where
am i going to work
where am i going to work after eight
years here christy mcgill looks at what
is left of her salon buff the nail
boutique a fire caused a roof to
collapse at this building monday morning
once they let us in we'll see what we
can salvage
the fire was so intense more than 70
firefighters were needed to put it out
wow i was shocked vincenzo pellegrini
says he was worried about it spreading
to his bridal dress shop bridal xoxo man
if if all the dresses catching on fire
for the brides for those brides that
getting married this week
was going to be a catastrophe but
thank you god now he is trying to get
the lingering smoke smell out of the
building investigators were looking
through the debris much of monday trying
to figure out what could have caused
this i'd like to know where it started
there's new construction going on and
remodeling in our building mcgill has
insurance but now has to figure out the
next steps just
move forward and rebuild
maybe not in this location but
go somewhere else
back out here live you can just see all
this debris that was taken out of the
building uh crews just finished boarding
this all up investigators have not said
how much exactly the damage is estimated
to be here and they're still looking
into that cause reporting live john
mulder live local now